no sólo necesitan ganar una imagen de
legitimidad ante la comunidad
internacional a nivel interno los
talibanes se enfrentan el reto de
mejorar la golpeada economía de
afganistán que según el banco mundial
depende de la ayuda internacional sin
embargo no todos ven con preocupación el
cambio de régimen
desde que llegó el nuevo gobierno estoy
feliz porque hay gran seguridad en la
ciudad
los estrictos controles en diversas
calles del país son percibidos como una
mejora considerable
por el personal de seguridad chequea
cada carro en busca de ladrones o
terroristas suicidas
los ciudadanos aseguran que la llegada
de los talibanes ha dado un impulso
indirecto a diversos comercios estos
fabricantes de banderas se han visto
favorecidos
el negocio está mejor y se ha acelerado
la impresión de banderas por su alta
demanda
pero aún se desconocen todas las
políticas que tendrá el nuevo gobierno o
si cumplirá las que ya anunciaron la
incertidumbre es una de las razones por
las que se ha disparado la venta de
armas
aquí vendemos armas a las familias que
vienen y a los talibanes me también
vendemos estas balas aquí están las
armas que han sido saqueadas de los
puestos de control y otros lugares del
país si alguien tiene un arma robada nos
la venderán garcía el recelo es
frecuente entre las mujeres y el
personal educativo
estamos enfrentando la incertidumbre
necesitamos que cumplan sus promesas
días atrás los talibanes dijeron que no
nos dividirían por género pero luego le
pidieron a los directores de las
universidades que haya clases separadas
y remotas para pese a que las
manifestaciones fueron prohibidas
pequeños grupos de mujeres volvieron por
segundo día consecutivo a las calles de
kabul para exigir a las nuevas
autoridades que sus derechos se respeten